what is up guys my name is Jonah and
welcome to episode 11 of 30 game
programming in Java okay it is a good
day today I've had a good day today
anyway just came back from party and I'm
pumped basically and you guys might be
like just came back from a party what
time is it like - am NOT it's it's time
to do this tutorial there's what it's
time for speaking of time actually I've
been thinking about about this and I'm
like this is really stupid this sort of
thing we have going here so before we
are before we move on I want to sort of
fix this so we sort of made something
here with time changers back to time
plus plus we made a public entity called
time and stuff like that and we we want
to basically sort of advance that we
want to use that time to to do this
stuff so instead of adding time here
let's just sort of see our result as it
was right now okay so instead of using
this time what we want to do is use them
use that time so we're just going to
basically add an instance of that class
an object of that class called game of
course and we'll come in here and change
this to game till time no I'm and we can
raise this you know we can erase this
and let's check that out
what's our screen okay again and we
simply need to uh maybe not okay let's
run this okay so that seems to work
awesome
yeah and that's pretty simple what we
have to do is that okay wonderful let me
just bring up display
okay so next thing so yeah we've sort of
fixed up time here um and that's kind of
important because it was a bit messy now
just got game dot I'm sort of doing that
I'm Alex I'll quickly explain how this
works because I'm releasing a story once
a week now you know this tutorial is
gonna be pretty long so yeah he all of
you guys said that you like a long one
so here we go
okay so if we go back into display the
reason that this works is that first of
all while it's running it's ticking
right and untick its game tick so when
it goes to tick it goes to the method
called tick in the class called
wall game so let's go to tick and it's
got time plus plus so basically every
time every time this running thing sort
of passes through and execute this code
1 is being out at a time because it's
sort of ticking and that's how we you
know get time plus plus and that is kind
of nice I guess actually let's just
let's go ahead and clean off this cover
I need this test stuff anymore just
remove that okay let's come back here
this is really so nice I like to have
displayed semantically our main class
first up here well what are you doing
Eclipse I'll just close this for a
minute okay
bring up render as well put that before
this then put screen and game can sort
of maybe be here
okay now we're organized okay so yeah so
that's that sort of cleans that off and
we're gonna do a rotation today because
rotation rotation chorus core
perspective rather than an aesthetics in
other words rotation rotation rotation
rotation yeah um okay so basically
rotation so that's what we're doing okay
I told you guys to vote you guys voted
this is on my channel by the way so if
you want to vote for something I asked a
question you guys you guys wrote your
responses it's better than the comments
because I actually you know both bother
to read these I'm joking outright all
michaelis so yeah that's all my channels
so you
that out and there'll be an episode 12
thing here asking what you guys wanted
to for episode 12 which I don't know
what what it is yet basically one's
gonna she's gonna say how we go with
this tutorial and figure out them figure
out what's next after rotation so yeah
so let's talk about rotation um so we've
got our basic forward movement and let's
just stop that actually it's coming here
quickly and stop that okay and actually
we could also have put that here I
believe okay so that's left and right
working just checking and then that's
what is this didn't I copy the whole
thing apparently not yeah okay so
everything works at this point and don't
worry about the flashing stuff and
render distance we'll do that later
um we'll fix that later I mean okay so
yeah let's talk about rotation rotation
comes down to a few different things and
it's basically the cosine and the sine
maths operators working together because
as you know a sine graph okay more
explaining I'm just actually I want to
be a rebel today and use paint instead
of paint up now that's pretty it's
pretty up there so that's I hope you
guys can deal with that because that's
pretty it's pretty tough okay the
easiest way to show this is sort of like
a sine graph okay I hope you guys know
what a sine graph looks like you need
maths if you feel pretty few learning
how to program and you don't know maths
then especially game programming and you
don't know Mouse and well learn maths
sine graphs looks like that look like
that and cosine graphs look like this
okay well that's supposed to be there
but anyway that's what a sine graph
looks like and let me just make some
room here and the cosine graph looks
sort of it's sauce up here so it's like
the oh it's sort of like the opposite
and what you can imagine is okay that's
going this way and that is going back up
so it's not really changing but if we if
we also use the inverse of it which is
this cosine graph we can sort of get it
to complete a whole circle instead of
going to two to two and and meanwhile
cosine is going to do two
to herbalist on those sound effects are
helping you guys out because uh okay
anyway and you can say that if we if we
sort of combine those two we get a
circle and that's sort of how rotations
gonna work so using paint there was a
bit of a I don't even know what to call
it a bit of a bit of a you know a
high-profile move there um but yeah
paint on out will be will be used later
I assure you guys um okay so yeah so
let's let's let's start adding that so I
want to make three doubles here three um
three variables one of them one actually
called rotation because this is gonna
sort of dictate rotation and I don't
know we'll just put it to game doll time
divided by odd night 10.0 something I
don't know 100 and this is actually
going to actually animate the rotation
for us and what we need to do now is
create basically a cosine value which
will be math dot cos and with rotation
in here and also a sine value and
that'll be math dot sine and then
rotation okay so now we've got now to
sort of I guess up maths operators done
and basically the the value of cosine is
going to get dictated by rotation and
rotation is basically animated because
we're using game dot time and and game
door time the variable time in the class
game is constantly increasing so let's
go ahead and um basically we're gonna to
now just add this so hmm okay so let's
let's multiply this by cosine and then
we'll have to add the inverse of that
which is head and then multiply it by
sine and hopefully this will work and I
want to do basically the same thing here
so it'll be times cosine except this
time it's going to be minus the depth
and times sign okay so that let's check
that out and let's see what we get that
yay rotation okay so it's pretty simple
as you saw that again you know it's
pretty simple you probably wouldn't know
what what would happen if I didn't put
that as you can see it gets sort of
halfway and then it's tucked starts
going back and that's basically exactly
what happens because it goes like that
and then it stops then it goes back
because the sine graph goes like this
you know but if you want the whole
circle then you have to add cosine in
there as well because cosine does the
opposite of sine it goes like that I had
to add those two together except
subtracted of course instead of added
and you know what's we're adding here
and we're subtracting here and you get
you get you know complete rotation I
mean a circle so yeah don't worry about
all this stuff again the render distance
will take care of that I think we're
good
hmm okay one more thing I wanted to do
actually actually let's just sort of
experiment with this upend wow that's
fast 100 was perfect comfort if I chose
that 1000 is really slow but you can see
even even like even if it's slowed the
resolution are wet like the quality of
this is really high which is really good
we really want to say that because um we
want eye game to look nice and at the
moment it's looking fantastic
what's our FPS our FPS is beautiful
right now we're talkin 102 frames was
100 frames per second with with infinite
render distance and well no textures but
we'll get onto that soon okay yeah so
that's awesome okay I want to deal with
a few other things as well and that is I
want to make a few operators a few
variables basically for for all the
different sort of heights because at the
moment I'm thinking that I want to sort
of play around with the ceiling height
and everything let's go ahead and check
this out okay so I think if we
if we add let's check this out
if we add on a valued of here
+5 say oh okay that's gonna sort of move
the player position I guess oh wow yeah
I think we need to set this up
differently actually if we want to
control if we want to control on the hot
and stuff of this okay let's check this
out
okay so I've got a few okay how do I
want to do this let's move this here I
think that yeah that'll probably break
our Oh fantastic oh no no it's still
fine okay that's good
and I think this is the well yeah okay
okay that's fine so we got that and
let's actually come in here and we'll
change this to Z and we're gonna set it
equal to that just wiped out um to like
out on our four / - said yeah okay
that's good and if we increase this
value it shoot yet awesome so it's
moving everything up that's amazing
that's really lower point five yep okay
wonderful
so as you can see we can sort of start
to control basically the heights of the
ceiling here I think falls a bit lower
okay that looks nice it looks nice okay
that's cool and now we sort of do have
to do like the exact same thing so for
the floor and the floor where the floor
located
um actually it should be yes it is here
fantastic
okay awesome that was surprisingly easy
okay so I'll explain this quickly
um actually screw this let's just call
this floor position and let's call this
ceiling position and this is sort of
vertical position I could call a
vertical position but I don't want to
full position what do we have it out
like out on our four and double ceiling
position and we'll set that to I don't
know eight I think we heard it up
apparently not
what was it four pups we had this a day
and this it alright Alex nice okay so
let's come in here real quick and I'll
sort of explain this stuff yeah so we
basically created a way to move the
floor vertically and a way to move the
ceiling vertically and this and move
them separately so if we if we sort of
increased this you can see that it's
making the ceiling even higher and
basically what will happen is if we
increase this to something it's
something like a huge number you can
still see it now because there's no like
it's it's rendering in infinitely it's
not gonna stop rendering when it reaches
a certain distance which is what we
wanted to do it basically so when it
goes above the render distance and a
thousand will definitely be above the
render distance eventually when we
actually add render distance limited
limitation and because it's because it
will be above it simply will be black it
there won't be anything there so yeah so
for now you can still see it even if we
increase this to basically like that we
can still see it because it's you know
it's gonna be sure an infinitely until
we had that limiter but you can see how
that does that and the same thing
happens with the floor okay take the
floor away so that's awesome that's sort
of how we're going to
an open sky as well we'll just simply
increase this to like 1000 or whatever
and that'll be gone okay awesome so yeah
you can play around with this get
something that you like
I'm actually really like that doesn't
look too bad but I like 8x8 I didn't
hate it sort of hits the spot for me I
like the number 8 actually that's my
straight address number eight okay so I
think was pretty sweet okay there's a
few yeah okay
so let's just go over basically what
we've done so fast that we can decide
what to do next
um so where's our rotation okay let's
sort of shut off rotation for now so
we've got rotation we've got forward
movement which I'm just about it ad just
call this forward forward and call it a
sudden oh right and double double
forward equals game dots so I'm divided
by 100 and back sorry right it's going
to be the same thing
maybe 10
yells nice okay actually I think that
might be their other way around yeah it
is okay so that's forward and that's
right
so if we what's going forward yes and if
we increase forward then yep
okay so we've sort of got that working
it's going really slow it's alright and
you know I assume if we want to make it
go left then we just yeah we just wish
that's negative or we could actually
just divide it by negative five and that
would make it go left and if you know
maths which you should by the way a
double negative equals a positive so
would go go right again okay so yeah so
we've basically got controls here hum
and actually now that I think about it
we could have some key movements to this
so we come to the base we've basically
come to the end of our tutorial today
for this week and I don't know we've
okay so we've added a rotation basically
so let me just bring that up and we can
actually test our rotation along with
everything else yeah that's nice
okay looks good okay awesome it works it
works with the Little Theatre sort of
controls which is good okay
so we've had a rotation today um as you
guys requested and I think and we've you
know we've done controls we've had we've
simplified this to game dot time instead
of time just normal and and a local
variable called time we've actually set
this to tick and yes we've done quite a
bit today um which is good so now we've
sort of come to a fork in the road week
off the top of my head I think that I
could think of about three things which
we could do next we could do the the the
render distance limiter which wouldn't
be a bad idea at this point because
that's pretty much the only thing
ruining the look of our game and that's
this crap in the background so we could
do a render distance limiter what else
what else we could also do textures over
and another thing I wanted to bring up
with with textures is I sort of comment
the other day which that was which um
said that uh did you know that it's
better to focus on the core sort of the
core stuff rather than the aesthetics
and the core the core core core
components the core components instead
of the aesthetics and I think that's a
really good idea personally I liked it
that I always did it do it that way you
know we get everything working with this
generic sort of texture and then we
actually start working on the aesthetics
and making it look nice and importing
our own sort of textures and other stuff
like that like 3d models will be doing
3d models as well don't worry about that
I'm not gonna teach you guys how to
model um I actually got another channel
which deals with with sort of with video
like stuff like like like three 3d
studio max and all that all that good
stuff
um but yeah we will be using 3d models
probably for guns will be for 3d objects
and all that stuff so don't worry about
that
that's aesthetic holder so I'll probably
do that after the core gameplay stuff is
worked out so yeah so you've got the
choice with we've pretty much got the
choice of either the the render distance
limiter
the textures I really don't want to do
but if you guys really want now what I
want to do is just throwing that out the
window so we got that we got the render
distance limiter or we we have the
controls so we could actually add player
interactions so you guys can actually
walk around using the W SDKs and look
around with the mouse or with the case
with the keyboard and yeah and but we we
could basically add user interaction
that controls user input so yeah so we
see the radio distance limiter or the
controls again go to my channel as last
time and you know you'll see um you'll
see that little question thing or drop a
comment below whichever you prefer but
I'd prefer for you guys who actually
posted on my channel so that it you know
I can I can basically see only sort of
what to do not just other just general
comments mixed in with general comments
so yeah go ahead and head over to my
channel like this video favorite of this
video I don't know if you liked it do
whatever you want and yeah I'll see you
guys next week with whatever you guys
choose to do so yeah see you guys later
bye